bloody near Putin a friends to all in
the Middle East from the leaders of Iran
and Turkey to Israel and Syria Putin is
presenting himself as a mediator who can
be relied on since Russia began its
military campaign in Syria in 2015 the
country has become an important player
in the region Russia joined forces with
Iran to back the Syrian government
providing air support
[Music]
most recently Russia and Syria have
stepped up their bombing campaign in
Midland province the last remaining
rebel stronghold Russia's military
support has helped prop up Syria's
President Bashar al-assad and guaranteed
Moscow an important geopolitical
foothold in the Middle East as the u.s.
pulls its troops out of Syria Russia has
remained our armed forces and our
military equipment have demonstrated the
growing power of the Russian army and
navy and the high combat capability of
its forces Russia also condemned the
u.s. assassination of Iranian general
Qasem Soleimani this week as reckless
and has repeatedly back tear on in its
ongoing confrontation with the US Putin
consistently criticizes American policy
in the Middle East and has tried to
present Russia as a more reliable
partner after US President Trump decided
to pull out of the Iran nuclear deal in
2018 the Russian leader has repeatedly
said his country would continue to
support the agreement we believe that
the only sensible decision is for all
the participants in the Iran nuclear
deal to honor their commitments and that
is exactly what Russia intends to do
this week Putin called for a ceasefire
in Libya as well fighting there has
escalated in recent months and although
Russia has refused to officially side
with one of the warring parties
according to media reports Russian
mercenaries have been on the ground for
months
supporting general Khalifa Haftar
against the un-backed Libyan government
as US influence in the Middle East wanes
Russia is working hard to fill the void
we've got some analysis on Merkel's
visit to Russia
let's bring in DWS Emily show and in
Moscow and here in the studio is our
political correspondent Thomas Sparrow
Thomas we'll start with you before these
talks today Merkel spokesman said Russia
was an important actor on the world
stage very praising words indispensable
in solving political conflicts what is
it that Merkel wants from these talks
today with Putin in short Merkel
probably wants some clarity as to what
role Russia could play to try and
deescalate tensions in the region
Germany is aware that Russia plays a
very important role when it comes to
Iran when it comes to Syria when it
comes to Libya and those are all issues
that are going to be discussed today or
that are probably already being
discussed between the Russian leader and
the German leader and it's important to
stress that these two leaders have met
on many many occasions in the past
they've been in power for a very long
time in Russia and in Germany they know
each other very well they speak the
language of each other's countries or
Mangala Merkel speaks Russian and
Vladimir Putin speaks German they know
each other they said very well and as
such I think that explains why Germany
in particular not for example another
country another leader of another
European country went to Moscow to try
and find out exactly how Russia as a
very influential player in the Middle
East could try and help to deescalate
tensions so two leaders with a very long
established working relationship Emily
will go to you Merkel is really after
putin's influence here how is this being
viewed in the Kremlin well that
absolutely plays into what the Kremlin
wants Vladimir Putin has taken care in
recent years to very much present
himself as a key player in the Middle
East and as a mediator in Middle East
conflicts as Thomas said when it comes
to Syria in particular and in the run-up
to this meeting we've seen kind of a
flurry of diplomatic activity from Putin
as well he met with the petha Syrian
President Bashar al-assad in Syria this
week and he's also been talking about
Libya a lot he spoke to aired on
Turkey's leader this week in person and
he's been made
making calls yesterday and today he
spoke to three leaders about Libya and
has been calling for peace there so I
think he's really taking care to present
himself as the key player that miracle
can look to and especially as a player
that is more reliable than the US Russia
has also taken care to kind of present
the US and Donald Trump in particular as
reckless when it comes to the Iran
nuclear deal when it comes to the recent
killing of the Iranian general Soleimani
which Russia also called reckless and
today they will be hoping to kind of
bring Germany that important partner as
Thomas said on side so speaking of the
Iran nuclear deal we'll go back to you
Thomas
Germany and Russia want to salvage this
but Iran has said in light of what's
been happening with the u.s. it's
scrapping its nuclear enrichment limits
as dictated by the agreement what can
Russia and Germany do about this
Germany's foreign minister in particular
said that Germany still wants the Iran
nuclear deal but it is not willing to
simply stand by and watch while Iran
takes step steps away from the Iran
nuclear deal and it's important and
that's probably why one issue that will
be discussed is exactly how they can try
and make sure that Iran complies as much
as possible with the Iran nuclear deal
another issue that is particularly
important at this year in Germany as
something has been developing also in
recent times is that idea that Donald
Trump presented that may be another deal
should be discussed a broader deal with
Iran that not only focuses on its
nuclear ambitions but there includes for
example its role in the region its wider
role in the region and we've heard from
several German politicians saying that
maybe Germany should also try and
discuss whether that is a possibility so
I do expect are in the discussions
between Vladimir Putin and Angela Merkel
they will also discuss whether another
did another deal with Iran which also
includes those regional ambitions could
be in any way discussed and included
okay Emily there's a there's a lot
happening today as we've been hearing
what else can we expect from these talks
well it seems likely that the two
leaders will touch on North stream two
after set us sanctions against that gas
pipeline between the two countries were
brought in
December but also a particular focus
today seems to be Libya Berlin has been
pushing for a peace conference on Libya
in the coming weeks to take place in
Berlin and it seems that Russia could be
on side when it comes to that Putin has
been calling for peace he's been
speaking to leaders calling for a
ceasefire in Libya so it seems likely
that Putin may come out and support that
conference in fact he also cautiously
already supported it along with air
Dewan this week Russia of course hasn't
officially taken sides in that conflict
but they have potentially been tacitly
supporting half star in his advance on
the u.s. UN backed government in Tripoli
with mercenaries but it seems that again
there on Libya we can be we might be
seeing a united front of between Russia
and Germany today a correspondent in
Moscow Emily Sherwin Thank You Emily and
here in the studio a political
correspondent Thomas Barrow thank you
very much Thomas